hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ihr habt wahrscheinlich schon vor
ein paar tagen das video gesehen was ich
gedreht hat murat zusammen über die
leiter und wir sind ja gerade noch dabei
spendengelder zusammen für ihr leider
und damit eben bald besser geht und sie
ihre therapie bekommt und jetzt kamen
natürlich mittlerweile auch ein paar
fragen auf und wir wollen jetzt einfach
die größtmögliche transparenz bieten und
jetzt einfach eure fragen klären und aus
diesem grund habe ich jetzt den papa von
dir leider eingeladen und wir sitzen
jetzt hier bei einem freund im
restaurant und ja ich denke dass jetzt
die ganzen fragen klären können und dass
du uns einfach so ein bisschen noch was
erzählen kannst ich glaube die
meistgestellte frage weiß einfach wie
geht's leider überhaupt im moment danke
dass ich hier sein darf dann gehe das
ihr euch um uns kümmert dass ihr diese
aktion gestartet habe diesen aufruf da
will ich erst mal beginnen
leider weiß dass ich hier bin ich soll
euch liebe liebe grüße sagen auch von
meiner frau vor älteren tochter
herzensangelegenheit dass das wissen die
menschen und die allermeisten gestellte
frage wie geht es weiter
leider ist seit vier jahren an leukämie
erkrankte jetzt aktuell seit über knapp
drei wochen jetzt fast in der
stationären aufenthalt in tübingen in
der klinik und es ist ganz einfach so
dass sie keine immunabwehr hat wenn ich
da ganz kurz erklären darf warum hat sie
keine immunabwehr warum es in der abt
lasse sie sind isoliert sie ist isoliert
sie hat infektionen sie vollständig man
kann sie jetzt momentan auch gar nicht
so 100 prozent unter kontrolle erhalten
weil ich jetzt genau vor knapp drei
wochen bei der sehr wichtigen
knochenmark funktion durch knochenmark
funktionen kommen immer diese ergebnisse
wie sieht überhaupt im körper mein
knochenmark aus
da waren wir schon eigentlich gewappnet
weil wochen vorher schon die anzeichen
mit gliederschmerzen etc wieder
wiedergekommen sind leider hat dann nach
dieser knochenmark funktion einen tag
später gleich die diagnose bekommen
rein rechnerisch haben wir alles
schriftlich 100 prozent sein bedeutet
ohne chemotherapie sehr intensiven
chemotherapie wäre leider jetzt nicht am
leben und ich habe den ärzten noch
vorkommen mag funktion gesagt ihr könnt
nachher oder einen tag später wenn man
ins gespräch kommen was zu machen ist
wie es aussieht
ihr könnt alles anbieten aber keine
chemotherapie
wieso wolltest du keine chemotherapie
weil wir in diesen vier jahren gesehen
haben was mit deinem kind passiert ohne
chemotherapie also so oder so keine
chance du willst es nicht wahrhaben dass
dieses in anführungszeichen gift
jemanden heilen soll es gibt sehr sehr
viele beispiele wo es kinder schaffen
auch erwachsene natürlich allein durch
die intensive chemotherapie geheilt zu
werden
bei unserer tochter war es leider nicht
so ist es leider nicht so und genau auf
die frage haben die ärzte mir gar nicht
geantwortet weil ja schon mussten ja
meines ergebnis schlecht ist kann leider
eigentlich nur noch leben
diese diese gewisse zeit wenn wir mit
chemotherapie behandelt
aber die chemie wird dadurch jetzt nicht
ausgelöscht
nein das wird nicht ausgelöscht und
geplant war eigentlich eine fünftägige
intensive chemotherapie
wo aber auch der arzt gesagt hat fünf
tage ist in diesem zustand zu heftig da
verlieren wir sie auch wir werden jetzt
einmal eine dreitägige machen müssen um
dann abzuwarten was mit ihrem körper
passiert wie sie darauf reagiert die
möglichkeit dass sie durch diese drei
tage zusätzliche chemotherapie zu der
vorgeschichte von diesen vier jahren
sterben kann wussten wir auch aber
leider ist eben ein kind
so wie alle anderen kinder auch kinder
geben definitiv nicht auf
man braucht mehr als glück gottes segen
dass man überhaupt diese diese strapazen
dieser intensiven behandlung aushält und
in lager war immer ein kind ist ein kind
mit zuversicht mit zuversicht immer in
diesem kampf wie eine löwin ac bis heute
gekämpft aber wir sind jetzt eben in
einem in einem stadium wo es hier in
deutschland nichts mehr zu machen gibt
und leider hat leider seit gestern ein
paar werte die leicht steigen
und da kriegst du als vater wieder
weiche knie und denkst ja was ist jetzt
wieder los da kommt der arzt beruhigt
uns und wir haben diese diese diese
höhen und tiefen schon so oft erlebt und
wir sind wirklich froh das will ich
jetzt ganz am anfang auch sagen dass das
wir in deutschland leben
wir sind alle hier auf die welt gekommen
und wir sind sehr sehr dankbar für das
system
ich weiß viele menschen verstehen es
vielleicht nicht weil die krankenkasse
die therapie die wir vorhaben in den usa
als letzte möglichkeit nicht bezahlen
aus welchen gründen auch immer dazu
kommen wir denke ich auch später wichtig
ist ganz einfach dass das dass diese
message an die menschen weiter geleitet
wird und dafür danke ich euch auch wir
müssen dankbar sein
keiner verhungert hier keiner bleibt
einfach so obdachlos wir sind wir sind
leider in der situation dass wir ganz
unten angekommen sind ganz unten
es bedeutet wir haben normales leben
gehabt ich war im außendienst
beschäftigt meine frau
einzelhandelskauffrau aber mit der zeit
haben sich die dinge so entwickelt dass
du dann gar nicht mehr arbeiten konnte
ist er seit er aktuell auch mit weiter
in der klinik
ihr habt ja noch eine andere tochter ich
glaube sie sich zwei jahre älter als ihr
leiter und
wie macht ihr das mit ihr also geht sie
zur schule oder also schwierig bei der
erste erkrankung gleich an dem tag klar
niedergeschmettert mit der diagnose
sofort reagiert schulwechsel du lebst
jetzt bei der tante ja das war aus
unerfahrenheit man hat sich super um sie
gekümmert man hat sie mit in urlaub
genommen
es sind aber dinge die man sich gar
nicht vorstellen kann das ist ja ein
kind mit acht jahren
gibst du sie an die tante ab die sich
super um sie kümmert das thema ist aber
geborgenheit liebe
vater mutter ist eben was ganz anderes
und sechs monate ist auch eine verdammt
lange zeit für ein kind die nur diese
wochenende für paar stunden uns besucht
hat mal auch übers wochenende da
geblieben ist aber auf dieser
kinderkrebsstation mit so viel angst mit
respekt gegenüber anderen umgegangen ist
sie ist super gereift in diesen vier
jahren hat aber genauso ihre kindheit
nicht erleben können mit der schule hat
das natürlich längere zeit dann wieder
schulwechsel hat hat es ja geklappt dann
nicht und wir haben die absolute
unterstützung von von der jetzigen
schule auch für die die alena dass sie
ja die die ruhe auch braucht vor allem
dadurch schießen händen meiner mutter
groß geworden und es ist auch kein
geheimnis meiner mutter schicksal vor
zwei wochen auch in tübingen
eingeliefert leidet auch an krebs ich
will jetzt nicht detailliert eingehen in
die materie weil ich bin jetzt doppelt
betroffen ich konnte das erste mal
sieben tage gar nicht realisieren will
ist mir auf den magen geschlagen hat das
ich letzte woche ja auch oft der
notfallaufnahme lag wegen atemnot et
cetera
wichtig ist einfach zu wissen jeder hat
seine geschichte und glaubt mir 1
es gibt immer etwas schlimmeres als das
was wir erleben immer nur soll ich als
vater mich irgendwo hinter einer wand
verstecken und sagen okay das ist jetzt
unser schicksal
ich bin machtlos ich kann nichts machen
ich muss für meine tochter kämpfen was
sich vielleicht einige noch fragen haben
in der kreativ spendengelder für die
therapie im ausland als in den usa
und viele fragen ja dann natürlich auch
berechtigt wieso gibts die therapie
nicht in deutschland wieso muss ins
ausland pflegen das hat ja auch das
zieht ihr auch viele kosten mit sich und
wieso in den usa wieso nicht hier ganz
einfach klar zu stellen
deutschland ist in der forschung sowie
allgemein als land in der welt elite der
kleine max akzeptierende andere nicht
aber was wir in den vier jahren auf
gesehen haben die deutschen forscher
haben zum beispiel die allerletzte
therapiemöglichkeit hier in deutschland
dieses plena tumor ab diesen antikörper
wann würzburger forscher auch mit
beteiligt an dieser forschung auch
weiter entwickeln die amerikaner
pharmaindustrie da hat eine firma die
rechte aufgekauft detailliert weiß ich
das nicht
und dann geht es um studien ja in
amerika gibt es diese studien schon
schon länger und ich weiß auch von
unserem behandelnden professor der erste
patient der erste patient mit diesem
antikörper wurde in tübingen weltweit
behandelt hoch experimentell
ja und es ist immer noch hoch
experimentell es gibt diese studie und
zufälligerweise man wir haben ja auch
diese diese nachweise dass ein antrag
gestellt worden erst bei der
krankenkasse schon wegen der
antikörpertherapie und an dem tag 24 11
20 15 10 hat diese therapie gestartet
mit einer aktuellen studie so dass
dieser antrag bei der krankenkasse gar
nicht mehr gegolten hat und die
krankenkasse muss dann diese
antikörper-therapie übernehmen jetzt zu
dieser allerletzten möglichkeit von von
leider dieses album cover therapie hatte
er auch gemacht
die haben wir auch gemacht und es wird
alles das sind auch dass es auf dem
schweizer er das auch gescheitert
deswegen auch dieses vierte rezessiv von
leider diese katis therapie ist eine
hoch experimentelle therapie auch wieder
in den stuhl in amerika gibt es
verschiedene studien sehr viele kliniken
die das natürlich auch einsetzen aber in
den usa hier in deutschland sind ein
paar kliniken natürlich in der forschung
so oder so seit jahren mit sicherheit
dabei man möchte in frankfurt in der in
der uniklinik möchte man auch eine
studie beginnen
aber als wir diese niederschmetternde
das war für uns schlimmer als februar
2012 bei der erster kranken der dritte
november 2015 dritter offene rezessiv
drei stunden war ich mit meiner frau in
diesem zimmer
wer sie nicht rausgekommen wir haben nur
noch geweint nur noch geweint die
weichen knie etc
ja ich schäme mich auch nicht dafür es
geht um mein mein fleisch und blut
und hier ist es ganz einfach zu wissen
dass die menschen kein mitleid mit uns
haben sollen ja wir sind seit beginn der
erkrankung in der öffentlichkeit
und wir haben immer wieder versucht
aufzustehen ein normales leben zu führen
und dann kamen diese krankheit immer
wieder zurück immer wieder zurück um
warum zahlt es die krankenkasse nicht
weil es hoch experimentell ist man hat
noch keine langzeitstudien ergebnisse ja
und hier kommt das interessante weil
erst erkrankung 90% heilungschancen
sogar zwei monate nach der
erstbehandlung hat die leider keine
haare verloren
die ärzte waren super zufrieden mit den
ergebnissen da bist du noch mal einen
tick nach oben 95 prozent wo waren wir
mal irgendwann zwischenzeitlich wir
waren mal bei zehn prozent dann bist du
wieder hochgekommen auf 50 prozent
das sagt schon gar nichts mehr aus da
kann man mir jetzt irgend etwas erzählen
ja in dem gespräch
nach diesen drei stunden beinen und der
gedanke schon was machen wir wenn sie
sterben sollte allein dieses wort in
diesem moment wenn ich das nicht
überlege und plane ich habe drei
friedhöfe kontaktiert über freunde wie
viel es kosten würde und so weiter ob es
muslimische friedhöfe gibt oder auch
nicht
ich meine ich bitte die menschen das ist
unsere geschichte wir haben sehr sehr
viel schönes erlebt wir haben auch sehr
viel negatives erlebt aber hier geht es
einfach nur darum dass es dass die
menschen verstehen es geht nur um ihr
leider und leider hatte damals so wie du
in deinem video schon erwähnt hast so
wie es ja auch gesagt habe leider hat
damals die menschen durch video aufrufe
darum gebeten dass sie sich typisieren
lassen sollen ja bitte helft mir bitte
helft anderen laster basieren
warum macht sie es jetzt nicht papa
diejenigen die es nicht glauben
die helfen mir so oder so nicht es geht
um mich ich habe keine freunde ich bin
nicht in der schule ich bin ständig in
klinikaufenthalten ich bin isoliert hier
im krankenhaus ich bin isoliert auch zu
hause wenn jemand krank ist darf mich
nicht besuchen wo darf ich teilnehmen
da versucht man alles möglich zu machen
leider lebt in der digitalen welt und so
ist sie irgendwann auch auf dich
gestoßen und ich erzähle natürlich jetzt
umfangreiche es gibt sehr viel zu
erzählen
die therapie in den usa wird nicht von
der krankenkasse übernommen
dafür können wir nichts dafür können die
krankenkassen auch nicht natürlich gibt
es gesetzeslücken oder was man auch
verbessern kann
aber ich sage wiederum wir leben in
einem land unvergleichlich dafür muss
jeder dankbar sein jeder und wir sind es
dankbar
wir wollen dies auch zurückgeben nur in
dieser situation nur in dieser situation
muss ich nur an meine tochter denken
jetzt schon großteil des geldes zusammen
gekommen also theoretisch denke ich
schon dass es jetzt machbar wäre dass
die die therapie finanziert wird durch
dieses spendengeld was wird denn jetzt
passieren also im moment liegt sie noch
im krankenhaus und
wie geht es jetzt weiter also wann wird
es jetzt in die usa reisen geht es
überhaupt noch oder sie kann in diesem
stadium
sie kann in diesem stadium applus sie
leukozyten zwischen 50 und 200 ein
normaler mensch hat ab 4.000 aufwärts
sie habe wert blutwerte nicht über nacht
sondern unter 8 und dann kriegt sie
immer wieder auch transfusionen von blut
von thrombozyten bedeutet jetzt aktuell
ist sie gar nicht in der lage
man hat jetzt gestern begonnen ihren
knochen markt zu stimulieren man wollte
eigentlich ein bisschen länger abwarten
aber die zeit rennt uns einerseits davon
für uns ist es wichtig dass das die
menschen einst wissen wieso habe ich die
aktion im november gestartet obwohl wir
ja noch diese eine möglichkeit hatten
weil wir unser kind kennen und weil wir
ganz genau wussten
das hat vielen menschen vielleicht
geholfen aber nicht die leider schon am
ersten tag therapiebeginn mit der antica
partie mit der antikörpertherapie hatte
leider selbst gesagt die march fri kein
fieber ich krieg das nicht geht es nicht
ich glaube das wird auch nichts bringen
meine überlegung nach dem gespräch mit
dem professor war ganz einfach wo gibt
es die beste möglichkeit für meine
tochter philadelphia detailliert erzählt
welche unterschiede zwischen
philadelphia und anderen kliniken den
usa gibt deswegen auch die zahl 800.000
dollar
ja jetzt aktuell letzte woche donnerstag
23 uhr 16 ortszeit irgendwo um 16 17 uhr
schicken die mir eine e mail
es tut uns leid wir können leider gar
nicht therapieren
das hat aber auch den hintergrund ich
habe im dezember selbst initiative warum
bürokratie erst muss ja wieder etwas
ausprobiert werden
diese letzte möglichkeit warum muss
abwarten ob es wirkt oder nicht diese
antike ich im november diese aktion
nicht gestartet dann hätte ich bis
letzte woche freitag diese 100000 euro
die wir selber bis dahin gesammelt hätte
ich auch nicht gehabt und wir haben es
ja schon vorausgesehen und vor
ausgearbeitet dass wir beginnen müssen
und nicht abwarten auf was willst du
großartig abwarten weil du hast
praktisch immer einen schritt voraus
gehört und gedacht okay wir machen jetzt
diese antikörper-therapie aber was mache
ich wenn die jetzt auch wieder nicht
wenn so hast du in schön und konto
eingerichtet hat die klinik in
philadelphia kontaktieren und die haben
die gesagt die therapiekosten 800.000
dollar
es ist jetzt die absage bekommen ich
habe die arge bekommen weil ich
natürlich ein antrag das neue freundin
haben gesagt weil du gesagt hast du hast
dieses geld nicht oder erhöht er kommt
es auch drauf hin weil ganz einfach wie
ein antrag auch stellen mussten ich habe
eine englischlehrerin kennengelernt die
uns die arztberichte komplett übersetzt
hat die uns geholfen hat in 24 stunden
und zur verfügung zu stellen auf
englisch alles abgeschickt natürlich
wollten die aus philadelphia immer
wieder die die neuen diagnosen haben
haben sie auch erhalten
das thema ist ganz einfach so du liegst
sechs zeilen geschrieben und wenn ich
nach denen ihrer antwort gehen sollte
müsste ich ja wieder komplett aufgeben
und aufgeben gibt es bei unserem
reporter nicht aufgeben gibt es nicht
aber es gibt auch dieses nicht dieses
loslassen können
was meinst du wie viele kinder wir in
diesen vier jahren verloren haben wie
sich väter ihre köpfe gegen die wand
geschlagen haben wie sie am boden
zerstört waren
die musst du in diesem moment natürlich
auch aufbauen wie oft haben wir geweint
wie oft leid wie leiden wir darunter
ich muss niemandem erzählen ich habe in
diesen vier jahren jetzt gestern wieder
den siebten zahlen irgendwie verloren ja
die hälfte erhält drei jahren wohl drin
hast du die zeit denkst du an dich
selber überhaupt nein warum
warum warum arbeite ich nicht das ist
auch eine eine frage die sich viele
viele stellen genau wie ist es dann
passiert dass du jetzt arbeitslos wurde
erst erkrankung 2012 die ersten fünf
wochen bei der leider gewesen
in der klinik erstmal input was ist
leukämie wie geht's weiter da man ja die
prognosen gut
nach fünf wochen chef angerufen ich
komme wieder
beim außendienst beschäftigt und es hat
alles super funktioniert bis zu diesem
15 06 2012
diese daten vergesse ich nicht ich im e
center in freiburg damals war sie in
freiburg in behandlung meine frau ruft
mich an com bietet der professor mit mit
roten augen später von mir und will uns
sagen etwas erklären
bei der letzten knochenmark funktion ist
die krankheit bei der leider nach vier
monaten intensive chemotherapie so stark
ausgebrochen
das ist jetzt hieß sie brauchen einen
knochenmarkspender lieber professor ist
ein knochenmarkspender ja so und so eine
halbe stunde hat uns das erklärt
hochrisiko patient das und das passiert
aber wir brauchen einen spender
sie müssen sich typisieren lassen die
schwester muss sich typisieren lassen
und wenn man in der datenbank nichts
finden sollten
in der weltweiten datenbank dann sind
die chancen auf eine langfristige
heilung ihres kindes schlecht das war
die aussage was hab ich gemacht nach
einer halben stunde habe ich gleich die
dkms kontaktiert sofort google dkms
anruf sewikom usingen wir wollen eine
typisierungsaktion bis zu diesem tag
es ist so was ist eine knochenmarkspende
was ist die dkms ich wusste gar nicht
was ist aber daraus entstanden
25.000 menschen europaweit konstanz
singen stuttgart waldshut nürnberg
lauchringen tuttlingen in wien in
vorarlberg in zürich im türkischen
generalkonsulat in der türkei hat man
typisierungen studenten haben in
norwegen über facebook erfahren
sich dort so 50 auch typisieren lassen
die genaue zahl werden wir nie irgendwie
rauskriegen aber 25.000 menschen habe
ich als nachweis und 40 personen die
sich typisiert haben wegen unserer
ilayda ich glaube sie hatte er auch
damals dieses foto war ja auch noch ganz
groß
das hängt bei vielen familien die wir
persönlich nicht kennen immer noch
annähernd an der wand und leider ist es
eine 1 1 vorbildfunktion für viele
menschen und 40 die sich typisiert haben
bei diesen aktionen die mich kontaktiert
haben haben anderen menschen ihre
stammzellen oder knochenmark gespendet
und das war auch das ziel wir sind aber
nicht mehr leider in der situation dass
ich sage
leider braucht keinen spender leider hat
letztes jahr die transplantation hinter
sich unser spender und 20 jähriger
amerikaner oder wie auch immer wir
wissen das nicht
es bleibt anonym zwei jahre und dann
dürfen wir ihn wenn er selber will auch
kennenlernen
das wichtige ist ganz einfach dieser
spender hat angeordnet nimmt so viel
knochenmark wie es geht
um dieser person er weiß nur dass es ein
kind ist mehr weiß ja auch nicht
und wir sind wirklich verdammt dankbar
für diesen menschen dass er dass er das
gemacht hat
meiner tochter harz zwei monate etwas
gebracht dass keine leukämie zellen
nachzuweisen waren aber schon 60 60 tage
nach der transplantation hat man schon
wieder die anzeichen bekommen leute mit
ja und es ist es ist es ist einfach
grausam immer wieder diesen rückschlag
rückschlag ich als vater kann viel
einstecken gar kein problem
ich brauche auch nichts kopf ist
eigentlich komplett leer ist alles
fokussiert auf die leider aber auch
meine auf meine ältere tochter
ich hätte meine frau auch im stich
lassen können wieso habe ich dann im
juni 2012 mein chef gleich angerufen
chef ich unterschreibe dir alles
ich kann nicht wo solches auto abstellen
abholen
er hat dann auch wunderbar reagiert
hatte gesagt okay da kannst du nicht zur
arbeit
du kannst noch behalten ja also ich habe
verdammt große unterstützung gehabt von
meinem arbeitgeber aber irgendwann habe
ich diese menschen auch und dann kam es
natürlich dazu du hast sehr sehr lange
nicht da er hat dann auch gesagt okay
fangen wieder an und schon 1 1
ein vierteljahr kann krankheit fertig
wieder bei ihm angefangen kam die
krankheit wieder zurück wollte mich auch
anders irgendwie orientieren beruflich
weil ich gesagt habe im außendienst
funktioniert das nicht ja und dann hat
er mich erneut eingestellt
ja ja erneut eingestellt eine komplett
andere positionen der in der firma mir
gegeben viel verantwortung gegeben es
hat wunderbar geklappt ein halbes jahr
der september 70 17
september 2014 ich unterwegs zu meinem
chef gespräch über zukunft auf der
anderen seite ruft mich meine frau an
schatz' kommen sofort in die
kinderklinik was ich jetzt lieber wieder
weiche knie
die kriege ich jetzt auch und dann
gleich zwei tage später die diagnose
leider ist erkrankt wieder intensive
chemotherapie und da ging es ja auch
nicht gut
und seit dem tag arbeite ich nicht
du bist hat irgendwann aus der
krankenkasse wirst du aus gesteuert es
ist so 78 wochen 78 wochen dann bist du
irgendwann bist du aus gesteuert also
man hat die unterstützung der
krankenkasse er kann ich jetzt nicht
sagen ja das war schlecht oder so nein
es war alles optimal wenn ich mir
vorstelle was andere mir aus dem ausland
die sich hier behandeln lassen wegen
anderen krankheiten in deutschland was
die mir erzählen
da bin ich war dort noch mal dankbar
dafür dankbar
irgendwann bist du eben beim arbeitsamt
arbeitslosengeld
siehst du arbeitslosengeld irgendwann
hört das natürlich auch auf irgendwann
bist du beim jobcenter und wir sind beim
jobcenter ja viele fragen sich jetzt
vielleicht wie geht das überhaupt wie
kannst du ein eine spendenaktion machen
willst einen arztbericht von leider
haben
der steht bei uns in der in der website
derjenige der es versteht der arzt ist
der weiß ungefähr was cyclophosphamid
ist gibt dieses wort in wikipedia in
google kameras nachlesen da siehst du
glaubst schwarz gedruckt senfgas an was
erinnert mich senfgas vietnamkrieg das
habe ich gleich den professor abgesagt
ihr wollt aber nicht hier meine tochter
vergasen in anführungszeichen hab dabei
lachen müssen hat auch die ganz andere
bedeutung im drucksaal ich will es
einfach nur erwähnen was du dann in
google zum beispiel lesen kannst was
sich irritiert aber im endeffekt ist es
so ohne diese käme therapien geht das
nicht wir haben auch alternative
behandlungen heilpraktiker alles
mögliche eingesetzt wir haben alles
mögliche eingesetzt wir waren so oft in
der situation dass wir wirklich wegen
unseren zwei töchtern so in der
finanziellen situation war dass ich
gesagt habe eine sehr große familie habe
ich in der unterstützung
die hast du nicht die hast du hast du
nicht am anfang okay wir sind umgezogen
ist umgezogen weil der professor gesagt
hatten sich schimmel in ihrer alten
wohnung sah in der küche vor fünf jahren
aber die kann auch hinter der wand und
sie sehen
schimmel nicht und es wäre besser wenn
sie aus der dreizimmerwohnung weil ihr
leider eventuell durch die therapie ein
eigenes zimmer braucht also 500 euro
miete bezahlt und jetzt zahl von über
1000 euro miete
wir sind dankbar als wir haben einen
aufzug es ist alles behindertengerecht
aber in der situation denkst du nicht an
das finanzielle
was dich aber irgendwann wieder einholt
und du nachhilfe schreist und ich
bedanke mich bei jedem der von anfang an
uns unterstützt hat alle helfer aller
organisatoren
jede firma jede einzelne person alle
kinder die für ihr leider gemalt haben
geschenke
uns hat man auch finanziell unterstützt
aber wie gesagt wie gesagt das ist immer
sind immer fremde gewesen in der familie
vielleicht fünf prozent
mehr kann ich dazu nicht sagen es ist so
ja da soll sich keiner irgendwie
gegenseitig anlügen haye war es gibt
fälle wo es wirklich diese diesen
zusammenhalt gibt ja aber tut mir leid
dass das muss heute auch mal
angesprochen werden es kann nicht sein
ruf mich an wenn du was brauchst das
heißt ja was brauchst du was kann ich
für dich tun und das ist dieses dieser
unterschied ja ihr habt getan
ja ich tue jetzt etwas und nicht ich
gebe dir jetzt etwas und ich wünsche dir
viel glück und das ist dieser riesen
unterschied was er bewirkt habt durch
diese e-mail von von der partie ja das
ist unglaublich wie viele menschen wie
viele promis haben wir ja schon
kennengelernt was habe ich als vater
alles mögliche getan
so saß ich schon wie viele interviews
habe ich schon gegeben
ich muss dazu sagen die also angefangen
hat ja der kontakt über die fahrt mache
ich dachte ursprünglich das hat man eine
verwandte von euch wäre aus wie eine
wildfremde person also die hatte er
wirklich nichts mit euch zu tun sie
hatten nur über drei jahre lang eure
geschichte verfolgt und hat dann
irgendwie herausbekommen dass die leider
meine videos schaut und hat mich dann
eben drum gebeten so ein kleines gruß
video zu machen und so hat das ja alles
angefangen hat sich wäre echt sehr
beeindruckt dass sie sich da so dafür
eingesetzt und deswegen sitzen wir heute
auch hier als auf die initiative von ihr
hin und
was ich jetzt natürlich viele fragen
also ihr leider ist gerade im
krankenhaus ist nicht ganz noch nicht
ganz stabil und sobald ihr zustand sich
stabilisiert möchtet ihr jetzt in die
usa reisen und staat die behandlung und
zettel machen
wie sieht es dann aus also ich habe mir
da auch viel durchgelesen es gab fälle
wo dann die die patienten nach ein paar
wochen schon wieder gesund waren wieder
heimreisen dürften es gibt fälle wo man
irgendwie noch nachbehandlungen braucht
wie kann man sich das vorstellen
also sie so es gibt ja wir haben das
wort zum glück aber es gibt eben
beispiele schon die es ja geschafft
haben mit der annähernd gleichen
geschichte krankheitsverlauf wie die
leider wenn du als als vater mutter als
eltern diese eine kleine hoffnung hast
dies eine kleine hoffnung da wird alles
in die wege geleitet alles in die wege
geleitet und wir haben eins gelernt in
diesen vier jahren es gibt keine zufälle
im leben jeder hat sein schicksal
es gibt keinen zufall es kommt so wie es
kommen mag und es ist auch kein zufall
dass wir uns jetzt getroffen haben dass
wir uns kennengelernt haben dass ihr und
unterstützt dass ihr diesen aufruf
gemacht haben und es ist es ist
schwierig überhaupt in dieser situation
jetzt dran zu denken
wir haben diese möglichkeit was ist aber
wenn wir dort sind und die leider kommt
nach fünf wochen behandlung nach fünf
wochen behandlung ins koma diese
beispiele gibt was ist meine tochter
nicht in fünf tagen nicht in sieben
tagen erst in sechs monaten aus dem koma
erwacht jetzt will ich einfach dazu
kommen die heilungschancen sind riesig
und diese chance diese allerletzte
möglichkeit wollen wir nutzen
leider selber glaubt sehr daran dass
diese therapie sie heilen wird dass sie
schwimmen gehen kann dass sie freunde
hat dass sie wieder in die schule gehen
kann
papa ich will nicht umziehen ich will da
bleiben wo ich bin
ich will nicht ständig wie meine
schwester von der schule zur anderen
schule wechseln
ich will einfach nur leben und sie weiß
ganz genau dass das sehr sehr hart sein
wird und sie kämpft ja schon seit vier
jahren wie eine löwin und wir wissen
nicht was auf uns zukommt und deswegen
wir hatten 90 95 heilungschancen da man
wir ganz unten und es so eine lange
geschichte
da kann ich jetzt keinem sagen und nicht
die garantie geben
800.000 dollar 500.000 euro eine million
euro das geld ohne geld geht leider
nichts und wenn jetzt morgen jemand
kommt und wir behandeln euch komplett
kostenlos komplett alles mit unterkunft
jährigen flüge gesponsert hey ich sage
doch nicht nein dazu aber wenn ich
ständig diese große frage habe wie viel
kostet die therapie kostet das
tatsächlich so viel wie war es bei der
anderen familie
ich bin mal jobcenter ich habe nichts
ich habe alle nachweise ich glaube mit
16 hatte ich meinen meinen mein erstes
girokonto und ich habe meine ersten
kontoauszüge von damals und jeder jeder
kann fragen ja was passiert mit dem geld
wenn ihr leider morgen versterben sollte
anders will ich ja gar nicht denken
ja es gibt so viele notleidende menschen
da draußen
warum wollte ich einen verein gründen
warum wollte ich an die stiftung gründen
wir wollen auch anderen menschen am mut
machen so wie es leider schon getan hat
aber es gibt es gibt sowieso schlimmere
fälle die auch hilfe brauchen auch
finanzielle unterstützung brauchen und
wir wollen das auch machen nur es ist
uns in dieser zeit nicht gelungen
ich habe jetzt nur noch die kraft für
meine für meine tochter und wir wissen
nicht was uns auf uns wartet ich kann
nicht sagen in vier monaten sind wir
dort es gibt auch nach behandlungen mit
sicherheit die leider soll auch spaß
haben in der zeit wo sie gestärkt ist
wir haben ja in diesen vier jahre
nicht nur wie roboter gelebt sondern
wurde erst dann nach der ersten
intensiven chemo behandlung gesagt hat
herr heldt wir haben kein spender
gefunden aber wir sind auch fertige mit
der intensiven therapie leiche mit
zahlen sind nicht nachzuweisen aber das
risiko ist groß dass es zurückkommt
genießen sie ihr leben was habe ich dann
getan stadt der liebe stadt der liebe
paris wollen wir ins disneyland wollen
wenn es europa park klar es gibt immer
menschen verrecken soll sie die habe ich
dann reagiert facebook soll ich soll ich
darauf antworten wie wie dieser mensch
mir mehr entgegenkommt mit buzz werden
wir alles beschuldigt letzte woche
dienstag soll ich in dubai gewesen sein
einen tag später in singapur soll
luxuskarossen fahren ich habe jeden
einzelnen nachweis jeden einzelnen nach
was jeden einzelnen beleg was ich
ausgebe und das ist das ist einfach
wichtig dass die menschen wissen hier
geht es nicht um mich um meine frau hier
geht's um ihr leider aber gleichzeitig
geschwisterkinder was macht man für
geschwisterkinder
was haben die ärzte die schwestern die
pflegekräfte die reinigungskräfte in den
kliniken für problematiken wer weiß dass
überhaupt das essen dieser krebskranken
kinder genauso wie bei den erwachsenen
über das das ist ein ganz anderes thema
aber genau dieses thema bin ich auch an
gegangen ich habe meine satzung für die
stiftung auch selber irgendwo
vorbereitet dies weitergeleitet jedes
einzelne punkt es gibt herzenswünsche ev
violette konzert leider ist ein riesen
fan von violetta ja das hat das haben
die uns ermöglicht einander fein hat
irgendetwas anderes ermöglicht aber nein
ich will nicht im luxus leben ich will
so lange ich gesund bin kann ich
arbeiten und ich habe mit zwei linken
händen die ich habe
technisch absolut unbegabt damals in
meinem berufsleben auch mal krananlagen
verkauft drahtseile verkauft
drei jahre in der buchhaltung jeder hat
sein sein sein seine geschichte ich will
einfach nur damit sagen wir sind ganz
normale menschen die um das leben ihrer
tochter kämpfen um nicht seit gestern
sondern seit dem 27
februar 2012 ich glaube damit viele
offene fragen beantwortet das uns eure
geschichte erklärt wenn auch nur kurz
und knapp ich denke die vier jahre haben
euch sehr geprägt und mitgenommen
möchtest du an dieser stelle mein
zuschauer noch was sagen ich möchte mich
in erster linie im namen meiner familie
bei euch bedanken
und ich möchte mich bei allen zuschauern
allen unterstützern allen helfern in der
vergangenheit jetzt aktuell
ich will mich einfach bei allen menschen
bedanken die uns unterstützen und bitte
lasst uns nicht im stich
seid dankbar das was ihr gesund sein und
danke nochmal an an euch alle
vielen dank ich möchte mich an der
stelle auch wirklich bei allen bedanken
ich muss ehrlich sagen als ich das video
gedreht habe und nachdem ich bei euch
war hatte ich ehrlich gesagt ein
bisschen angst auch weil ich nicht
wusste wie viel kommt jetzt zusammen
bekomme ich das hin und will jetzt auch
echt überwältigt und muss sagen wirklich
jedem einzelnen vielen dank danke dass
ich auch dafür eingesetzt habe und viele
andere promis youtuber ihr habt es
fernsehen mit eingeschaltet er wirklich
alle kanäle genutzt die man nutzen kann
und habe viele leute angeschrieben die
uns dann auch unterstützt haben als
haben sich wirklich viele blogger
gemeldet viele youtube haben dann auch
noch mal ein video gedreht haben ein
video verbreitet und es kam jetzt
wirklich eine riesensumme auch schon
zusammen aktuell heute morgen waren
sitzen 256.000 euro die allein aufs
spendenkonto eingingen du hast ja schon
100.000 vorher gesammelt das ist
wirklich eine menge geld und über 14.000
300 spender haben sich daran beteiligt
ich denke es werden noch viele weitere
mit dazu kommen wirklich macht weiter
teilt das video und ich werde ich auf
jeden fall auf dem laufenden halten ich
werde euch darüber berichten wie es
weitergeht ich hoffe natürlich dass
jetzt stabil genug wird und nach amerika
reisen kann
und die behandlung dort auch bekommt ich
denke es wünschen sich jetzt alle meine
zuschauer und alle tiere kennen was sich
jetzt noch zum abschluss sagen möchte es
haben sich natürlich auch viele andere
gemeldet viele andere seesterne wie
jetzt der murat sagen würde
am sonntag findet in vaihingen an der
enz eine typisierungsaktion für die
michael statt meike ist 15 jahre alt und
leidet jetzt auch an leukämie
leider ist es so dass sie keine
stammzellenspender braucht sondern
wirklich nur noch die therapie in den
usa ihr das leben retten kann
bei michael ist es aktuell so dass in
den stammzellen spender braucht deswegen
werde ich am sonntag also jetzt am 20
märz in vaihingen an der enz in der
waldorfschule seien die aktion beginnt
um 10 uhr das heißt je mehr leute kommen
und sich dort registrieren lassen um so
höher besteht die chance dass maike eben
auch einen stammzellenspender findet und
diese aktion das hilft nicht nur der
maike sondern dass sich der weltweit
allen menschen die an leukämie erkrankt
sind
denn umso mehr leute in der spenderdatei
sind umso höher ist eben die chance dass
man die passenden spender findet also
ich werde mir dabei sein wer super wenn
so viele menschen wie möglich
vorbeikommen
danke dass du heute da warst und wir
werden auf jeden fall auch weiterhin
unterstützen wir lassen euch alle nicht
im stich ich denke ganz viele menschen
stehen hinter uns und wir hoffen
natürlich dass alles ganz gut ausgeht
und dass die therapie war leider
anschlägt und sie bald gesund wird und
sie hat schon gesagt sie möchte mit
murat irgendwann mal grillen gegen
kuchen backen ich hoffe das können wir
alles zusammen erleben
hoffentlich ja ihr habt uns hoffnung
gegeben
vor allem ich leider so vielen dank an
alle und hilft uns weiterhin fleißig mit
und wirklich kann meinen dank echt nicht
in worte fassen was in den letzten tagen
passiert ist hat mich echt überwältigt
und danke euch allen